à quelques jours de la fin de la session
parlementaire ici au sénat je voulais
revenir vers vous pour évoquer certains
textes nous venons de voter le texte de
climat et résilience j'ai voté ce texte
bien qu'imparfait parce qu'il comprend
plus de contraintes solution nous on a
tous conscience il ya un vrai défi
climatique à a relevé à cette occasion
j'ai pris des positions très claires
contre l'éolien et pour soutenir le
transport aérien et l'aviation civile
nous allons commencer dans quelques
jours aussi les bases sur le texte
appelait 3ds et pour une meilleure
décentralisation une simplification
administrative fait ce que je souhaitais
et j'espère que les débats porteront
c'est plus de responsabilités confiées
aux élus locaux qu'on écoute les
terrains un exemple à travers un
amendement que je vais défendent pas de
fermetures d'écoles pas de fermeture de
classe sans que le maire ou le conseil
municipal ont soit consulté voilà je
voulais aussi attirer votre attention
sur la situation sanitaire le virus est
toujours là alors prenez soin de vous à
très bientôt
[Musique]